hello how can I help ya I got two rooms
left time
the audence is a secret hospital for
criminals everybody's gonna get fixed up
now verify your memberships and we're
off to the races this thing is coming to
blood it's always covered in blood whoa
this is America 85% of what I fix is
bullet holes
we did some numbers without all the
holes I'm in position to finish the job
put a new 30% raise for inconvenience
because you're [ __ ] gross thanks
pronounce lease I was talking about your
ass not your room allocation hey put
your dirty boots on the stuff on your
own else oh hey go [ __ ] yourself it's
here the king is in the building
you need to leave here right [ __ ] now
the wolf king of LA such a dumb like
that
I guess my ballroom days are over baby
this hospital was built on trust those
people don't always talk their towel
rule number one don't kill any other
gracious let's just skip the [ __ ] alone
and water in LA but it's raining
[ __ ] in here
I don't really want to do that this feel
like we got chemistry
[Music]
when I walk away don't jump on my back
okay if you do I'm gonna [ __ ] you up for
real this time
[Music]
you